Hi.
My name is Olivia Yao.
I'm a senior studying
mechanical engineering
and human-centered design.
And I'm currently
the editor-in-chief
of Infinite Magazine.
Infinite Magazine is the
student-run art and fashion
magazine on campus.
We really want to
provide a creative outlet
for all of our students
studying technical studies.
In addition, we're a place for
people to explore and have fun.
I'm Hamilton Forsythe.
I'm a junior.
I'm studying arts and design,
which is in the architecture
department.
I would say the
mission statement
is to give a voice
to the people who
feel like they're
underrepresented here
at MIT, which directly relates
to fashion, and design,
and culture, and
how we integrate
those things with
technology here at MIT.
I think coming out
of high school,
I was trying to find some way to
explore myself and explore who
I was as an individual,
and fashion really
allowed me to do that.
So the magazine has a bunch
of different ideas categorized
into spreads.
And each spread starts
with a student idea.
So a student will
come and approach
saying I want explore this
topic in my visual spread.
And we help the iterate
and refine that idea
into something that could be
presentable in a magazine.
From there, we help them secure
materials and secure models.
We have photo shoots
and then we have people
lay the spread out in InDesign.
It's a great balance between
group and individual work.
As a busy MIT student,
you know you can't do
every aspect of every design.
And you might not
even have the skills
to do those things as well.
I think the most interesting
project that Infinite's ever
done is the launch box that we
did last issue for our launch
event.
We created a 10 foot
by 10 foot room.
It was bodega style.
It was an interactive art
exhibit of pages and images
from the magazine.
And people could walk
in, take pictures,
explore the magazine
in a physical sense,
instead of just
flipping through pages.
The launch from last
semester was something
that I've contributed the most
to and felt the most proud of.
Being able to actually
come up with that idea
and build the launch box
from scratch on my own,
makes it really,
really important to me.
The Infinite community
is pretty special to me.
It's a lively group of people.
But what makes it
special is that we're all
interested in
growing creatively,
and we're all really supportive
of each other's individual
projects.
I definitely want to
keep expanding Infinite,
making it more
visible not only MIT,
but I also want to
start reaching out
into the Boston area.
And put MIT on
the map as a place
to be for fashion and design.